apple is considering according to Elon
Musk removing Twitter from its app store
which would of course shut down Twitter
and almost nobody in office has noticed
this or decided to comment on it except
for Ron DeSantis he's the governor of
the state of Florida he joins us tonight
Governor thanks for coming on so of all
the news going on in the world and
there's a lot of it you stopped on this
story and you commented on why why did
this catch your attention
well Tucker if you look what's going on
in China now the CCP they have been
posing the zero covid lockdown policies
they've been doing it on and off for
three years and you have people in China
that are really engaged in a noble
effort to protest which is basically
leninous rule so what is Apple doing
with that they are limiting the airdrop
function of the protesters so they are
serving basically as a vassal to the
Chinese Communist party then on the
other hand here in the United States
what are they doing they are trying to
get Elon Musk Twitter off the App Store
potentially which would be a huge blow
for free speech and so this is maybe the
most powerful company in the entire
world certainly one of the most powerful
companies in American history they
exercise more Authority in some respects
than even some governments do and
they're using their authority to protect
the CCP we'll also try to limit speech
here in the United States
while existing as an American supposedly
American company using our copyright
protections our rule of law to their own
Advantage they're benefiting from
America but working against our most
basic value which is Free Speech what
can be done about that
well Tucker in the States you know we
did Big Tech censorship Bill two years
ago it's gotten caught up in the courts
I think the U.S Supreme Court's going to
accept that case for this term Texas has
a similar case there's a conflict in the
circuits and so whatever the states can
do to protect people's rights to engage
in free expression and you know what
some of these companies do they get a
lot of benefits from the government as
you said Pat and things like that the
social media companies get liability
protection and yet they turn around and
they use that protection to marginalize
voices they disagree with so I think
from the Congressional perspective
though they need to look at antitrust
with these massive companies because
they are exercising massive amounts of
power over our society
so one of the companies was benefiting a
lot from the government the government
of the State of Florida actually was
Disney you you changed that so they just
switched CEOs because of that because of
what you did the new CEO was the old CEO
Bob Iger held a town hall for employees
and he said he regretted that Disney had
fought with your Administration over a
bill that you backed that banned
teachers from talking to kindergartners
about sex so then Disney's response LED
Florida State legislatures to strip as
you know of course because you backed it
Disney of its special status here's what
Iger said today
I was sorry to see us
dragged into that battle
um and I have no idea exactly what its
ramifications are in terms of the
business itself what I can't say is the
state of Florida has been important to
us for a long time and we have been very
important to the State of Florida that
is something I'm extremely mindful of
and will articulate if I get the chance
how do you respond to that he's talking
about you
we didn't drag them in Tucker they went
in on their own and not only opposed the
bill they threatened to get it repealed
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks and I don't care
what a burbank-based California company
says about our laws
going to Rhonda Santos of the State of
Florida thanks so much for that
we'll be right back thanks
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight